[Musica]
[Applauso]
grazie pene sono molto contenta di
condividere con voi la mia esperienza di
cambiamento nell'ambito professionale
nel quale ho però cioè la storia
dell'arte e in particolare la lettura
dell'immagine
ora va premesso che il mio primo
incontro con le opere d'arte avvenne
nell'ingresso della casa dei nonni
lì c'erano sei quadretti di paesaggio
che erano un 30 cm x 18 di altezza circa
e la cosa interessante era che spesso
venivano sostituiti
ora chiaramente penserete ma che
straordinari collezionisti erano i suoi
nonni
ebbene sì confermo erano degli
straordinari collezionisti soprattutto
nonna luigia ma di coperchi di scatole
di cioccolatini sua sorella la zia
ernesta ogni natale le mandava una
scatola di cioccolatini che aveva una
riproduzione di un'opera d'arte sul
coperchio se la riproduzione era un
quadro di paesaggio
bene allora avrebbe avuto l'onore di
essere messo in cornice ora la nonna
coinvolgeva anche me nella scelta del
paesaggio da sostituire perché
rigorosamente dovevano essere sei
quadretti all'ingresso chiar certamente
vi chiederete ma quale straordinaria
capacità critica vanno mai avuto una
signora che aveva fatto la seconda
elementare e una bambina di 4 5 anni
eppure per noi era una cosa serissima
con la lente d'ingrandimento si
guardavano i piccoli dettagli si
valutavano la luce il colore e a nessuno
delle due vi assicuro è mai venuto in
mente che in realtà noi stavamo
guardando delle banali forse anche mario
vite riproduzioni eppure sono convinta
che devo proprio a nonna luigia
l'interesse e la passione forse un po
anche l'ossessione per la lettura
dell'opera d'arte
immagini che chiaramente una volta
arrivata al liceo ho capito essere dei
quadri che stavano nei musei essere in
tanti posti soprattutto gli originali
non certamente nell'ingresso della casa
dei nonni al liceo a dir la verità c'è
stato il primo cambiamento perché le
immagini che ho iniziato a guardare
erano riprodotte sul manuale di storia
dell'arte ora il mio vecchio manuale di
storia dell'arte aveva delle immagini
patinate meravigliose una decina erano a
colori la maggior parte era in bianco e
nero
ora provate a pensare quale sforzo una
studente liceale doveva fare per
immaginare davanti ad una fotografia in
bianco e nero i colori della volta della
cappella sistina di un quadro di
caravaggio di kandinsky di pollock
qualche anno fa ho ripreso in mano il
mio testo di storia dell'arte quel
vecchio manuale e ho trovato un appunto
di fianco ad un abito di una madonna in
una scena della natività e diceva questo
diceva rosa ciclamino sbiancato dalla
luce
ora non è che avevo scritto rosa no rosa
ciclamino rosa ciclamino vuol dire che
quel rosa e carico di emozione perché
vuol dire i ciclamini del bosco il
profumo vuol dire l'effetto tattile
delle delle foglie
insomma io al liceo ho capito una cosa
che l'opera d'arte guardare l'opera
d'arte educa l'immaginazione e
soprattutto che guardare l'opera d'arte
è un passaggio assolutamente
fondamentale perché ci permette al
permette il nostro cervello di creare
dei collegamenti ed è con questa
convinzione che sono andata avanti negli
studi frequentato l'università e in
un'aula buia i miei occhi la mia mente
si immergevano a guardare quel fascio
colorato che dal proiettore andava su un
telo e mi immergevo in quelle
straordinarie opere d'arte opere d'arte
che poi chiaramente andavo a ricercare
sui libri talvolta anche mi capitava di
arrivare davanti all'opera d'arte con un
senso di attesa evidentemente
straordinario ed è così che sono
approdata 30 anni fa insegnare storia
dell'arte e qui un altro cambiamento un
altro cambiamento perché evidentemente
doveva insegnare ad altri a leggere le
opere d'arte da giovane insegnante d d
arte aveva un'unica convinzione che
bisognava mettere gli allievi davanti
alle immagini anche se erano delle
immagini riprodotte e fu così che inizia
i 30 anni fa appunto a fare lezione in
un'aula che gli studenti ribattezzarono
il pullman
ora avete presente un pool ma
all'interno di un pullman anni ottanta
c'era una stanza che era l'archivio a
scuola due metri di larghezza per 5 di
lunghezza due file parallele di sedie
uno stretto corridoio in mezzo tende
nere un proiettore alle loro spalle e
davanti a loro come se fosse il
parabrezza appunto di un pullman si
proiettavano le immagini delle opere
d'arte
e chiaro che i loro occhi si
spalancavano davanti a quelle
straordinarie immagini e l'ora
settimanale di storia dell'arte era un
momento di immersione totale in luci e
colori
ed è così che pian piano si educa vola
loro immaginazione valutavano anche in
un modo critico chiaramente le opere ora
è certo non mi serve più andare in
anticipo a scuola per
selezionare le diapositive da e mettere
nel carrello ora anch'io uso il power
point e lì le diapositive sono le
immagini sono già ordinate se non trovo
un immagine non c'è problema
internet mela da tranquillamente oggi
coi ragazzi si va spesso in giro si
vedono tantissime opere in italia in
europa bene direte arrivata la
conclusione i cambiamenti tecnologici
oggi ci danno la tranquillità assoluta
di non aver bisogno di immaginare tanto
basta un click e anche quello che non
abbiamo davanti ai nostri occhi appare
ma siamo proprio sicuri che non abbiamo
bisogno di immaginare di immaginare un
rosa ciclamino intanto che i nostri
occhi stanno guardando una foto in
bianco e nero perché per conoscere
bisogna immaginare
e se è vero quello che sosteneva
einstein che la conoscenza è limitata
l'immaginazione invece abbraccia al
mondo allora dobbiamo continuare educare
immaginare la nostra immaginazione e lo
scorso dicembre
ho vissuto un'esperienza che mi ha
confermato che l'opera d'arte e l'arte
sono sicuramente degli strumenti
particolarmente potenti per educare
l'immaginazione
anzi ho avuto un'esperienza che mi ha
detto che siamo un po tutti dei non
vedenti
si trattava di un incontro di un
progetto realizzato dall'associazione
nazionale ipovedenti di milano che si
intitola descrive dendo era una sorta di
sfida lanciata a noi vedenti perché
dovevamo trovare immagini e parole per
raccontare per descrivere un'opera
d'arte e l'opera d'arte scelta era
quella di de chirico
tiene dei gladiatori di de chirico
ora quella descrizione
iniziava così per cominciare
immaginiamo un grande dipinto di forma
rettangolare con il lato più lungo in
orizzontale alto come una persona di
media statura e largo come un lenzuolo
matrimoniale esteso riusciamo ad
immaginarlo
siete riusciti a vederlo
ora forse se chiudiamo gli occhi sì
vorrei che chiudesse un attimo gli occhi
per provare l'emozione che ho provato io
appunto lo scorso dicembre
e allora chiudiamo gli occhi e iniziamo
a immaginare di vedere uno dei tre
cavalli dipinti da de chirico quello che
sta in mezzo in piedi non è un cavallo
molto grande e anzi sembra più un pony
sulla sinistra ha una coda gigantesca
voluminosa riccia
ecco allunghiamo un attimo la mano la
riusciamo a toccare dalla stessa
sensazione di come quando ci mettiamo un
ci passiamo una mano tra i capelli
ora il quadro è chiaramente molto più
complicato di un cavallo
anche perché questo cavallo è in un
groviglio di corpi nudi di uomini di
gladiatori appunto anzi ri apriamo gli
occhi
vediamolo questo quadro capite che anzi
adesso magari fatica anche a cercarlo
questo cavallo ma è chiaro la
descrizione era durata un quarto d'ora è
secondo noi abbiamo guardato questo
quadro ma vi posso assicurare che dopo
quel quarto d'ora di descrizione davanti
semplicemente ad un telo
beh
anche chi è abituato a leggere le
immagini aveva vissuto un'esperienza
sensoriale immaginativa assolutamente
straordinaria ecco adesso si sono
arrivata alla conclusione che cosa è per
me allora il cambiamento
per me il cambiamento significa guardare
un'opera d'arte con gli occhi di una
persona ipovedente cioè avere un nuovo
diverso punto di vista da cui guardare
il mondo in fondo cambiare significa
proprio questo avere un altro punto di
vista immaginare qualche cosa che non
riusciamo neanche a concepire grazie
[Applauso]
scusate prima di lasciarvi volevo
assolutamente ringraziare catherine de
sena cles perché non sarai mai salita su
questo palco se non ci fosse stata lei
che mi ha dato anche il suggerimento
iniziale per questa nostra conversazione
grazie mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]